this right here is the m1 macbook air
and yes
i believe that it's the perfect laptop
now obviously no laptop can be truly
perfect because that's impossible
but as we've been testing it over the
last four months and comparing it to its
competition
it's becoming more and more clear that
nothing out there stands a chance
so in this long term review i'm going to
discuss why i think the m1 macbook air
is
so good i'm going to talk about how it
compares to some of the most
popular windows laptops out there and
then i'm gonna finish off with the small
number of downsides as well
so let's get right into it in our two
week review of the m1 air
way back then we admitted that we were
wrong
and if you haven't seen it let me give
you a quick rundown
when apple first revealed their new m1
mac lineup
we thought for sure that the m1 macbook
pro would be the better
buy because it came with a fan and
therefore
it would perform a lot better compared
to the macbook air
but as we started digging in and
comparing the two
we found that the air was keeping up so
well
that it doesn't make sense to pay the
extra 300
for the pro and then one day we modded
this m1 air by simply adding a couple of
thermal pads onto the heat sinks
and the performance skyrocketed to
levels
surprisingly close to the pro and to our
surprise it actually outperformed the
pro in a couple of the tests
so at that point we basically said that
it no longer makes sense for anyone to
buy the m1 macbook pro
because of how good this m1 air is at a
much lower price
now part of the reason is because the
pro is going to get completely
redesigned
in just a few months so it's definitely
not the right time to buy the pro
but in the case of the air most rumors
are pointing to a new model coming out
over
a full year from now and it's getting a
full redesign so it'll most likely come
at a higher
1200 price tag so because of that
it makes total sense to buy the m1air
right now
because you can find it on amazon for as
low as 950 dollars
by checking out the links in the video
description but getting back to why the
m1 air is so good
i want to start off by saying that i'm
definitely not alone
dave 2d recently made a video on it
concluding that the new air is such a
good value right now
that it's hard not to recommend it over
everything else out there
and analysts have been projecting very
optimistic sales for max over the next
few years mostly being driven by the new
apple silicon m1 chip
so yeah it's that good but other than
that
the m1 air is just incredibly solid all
around
the aluminum build quality is simply
unmatched
at this thousand dollar price point with
the air still being
incredibly thin for the amount of power
that it packs
the fanless design has been amazing
never having to worry about the fans
blasting anymore the new always on
feature is a much bigger deal than many
people make it out to be
since you never have to wait those
couple of seconds when opening it back
up after standby and just as it's always
been
the hinge design is perfectly weighted
for one-handed opens every time
the keyboard is fantastic due to apple
finally ditching those butterfly keys
the speakers are great sounding
incredibly clear and packing loud volume
and same with the microphones giving you
great quality
that's not always guaranteed on other
laptops but there was
one very important change that confirmed
our opinion
on the m1 air being the best choice and
that was the fact that the air finally
got the same
p3 wide color gamut as the pro has
making it an
excellent display even if it's limited
to 400 nits of brightness
so on the hardware and build quality
side the m1 macbook air
is an excellent laptop but what truly
made it great
was actually the software basically
everyone was expecting there to be
massive
software issues when the m1 max first
launched
due to it using a totally different
computing architecture
but as it turns out that never really
happened
right out of the gate rosetta 2 took
care of most of the apps that people use
on a daily basis
with ease and the crazy thing is that
single core performance
under rosetta still beat out every other
mac
out there so common apps ended up
working just fine
yes the whole software thing hasn't been
perfect
especially for plugins and things like
that but after only four months
it's incredible just how fast things
have improved and it's only looking up
from here
so in terms of an overall package from
the performance and the battery life
to the build quality and reliability the
m1 macbook air is a killer value
for just 999 dollars now of course there
are some downsides
but before i get into that it's time to
get into the
fun part comparing the air to its
competition
over on the windows side one of the most
premium windows laptops out there
is the dell xps which to some is the
macbook of the windows world
due to its premium build quality and
design the latest dell xps actually
starts at the same 999
price as the macbook air but
unfortunately it comes with an
extremely slow i3 chip with slower
g4 graphics and the display quality is
quite a bit worse as well
now because of that we went for a much
more expensive i7 model
which starts at at least thirteen
hundred dollars if you can get it on
sale
the macbook air ended up being faster in
basically every single way
and here's the interesting part the xbs
loses a ton of performance
when you unplug the charging cable which
the macbook doesn't do at all
on top of that the xps has worse speaker
quality
worse webcam quality and worse battery
life
so there you go the xbs was easily taken
care of by the m1 macbook air
while coming in at a lower price we then
tested out the new 14-inch lg gram for
1200
which is one of the latest windows
laptops with a lot of hope around it and
of course the
m1 macbook air absolutely destroyed it
in every single way
the build quality was terrible because
of how hard they tried to lower the
weight
making it incredibly flimsy the display
quality was much worse
especially due to the crazy amount of
reflectivity
the trackpad was one of the worst we've
seen in a while
the speakers were bad the webcam was bad
and the performance was of course
worse even though it's the best intel
laptop chip out there for laptops right
now
and making it even worse the performance
absolutely
tanked during longer term workloads like
being over
twice as slow as the air in cinebench
r23
and the macbook air was 60 faster in a
real world
lightroom classic photo export even
though it was running
under rosetta 2 and not natively so
just like the xps the lg gram also got
killed by the m1 macbook air in terms of
value
now here is the funny part people have
always made fun of apple for selling
overpriced
laptops but for the first time ever
the reality has flipped and the macbook
air
is now a much better value than its
competitors
and for the first time ever these
windows laptops
are now seen as overpriced compared to a
mac
and the main reason for that is of
course the new
arm-based m1 chip allowing apple to save
money
while greatly boosting performance and
now companies are starting to take the
apple silicon transition
seriously and they're starting to
consider following in apple's footsteps
by making laptops with arm-based chips
but either way
apple currently has a massive lead
because they're the only company out
there
who controls the software the chip and
the
laptop itself all at the same time
giving them a massive advantage and
looking at microsoft
they're still behind not even having
64-bit emulation
working well on their surface pro x
arm-based laptops
so with all that said the situation is
looking
great for apple but now let's finish
with the downsides
of course it only officially supports
one external display
but on the plus side you can easily get
around that if you really need
more by using special adapters and
software
and if you think about it most people
just use the laptop itself
another downside there are only two
thunderbolt capable ports
but keep in mind that the air has always
had that for the last few years
now i was gonna call this 720p webcam a
downside
but it just looks so much better than
the ones in the dell xps
and the lg gram so it's definitely not
that bad
and one of the biggest issues is that
you can't run boot camp
to play games but this isn't that big of
a deal
since the previous intel macbook air
overheated
so much that games were completely
unplayable
even with an external gpu trust me i
tried it
and thankfully there are some other
options for gamers like using parallels
or crossover
and games like league of legends and
world of warcraft play
great and so will anything in the future
that comes with apple silicon support
but other than that it's really hard to
find any other negatives about the m1
air
because the value at 999 dollars
is just so good for everything that
you're getting
so hopefully you enjoyed this review and
if you did go ahead and click the circle
about to subscribe
for more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two videos right
there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]